[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le meilleur de la
semaine politique et parlementaire à la
bouriane mancini bonjour marion est
notre invité cette semaine est le
sénateur socialiste du val d'oise
racheter mal bonjour et bienvenue et au
menu cette semaine
edouard philippe a présenté mercredi en
conseil des ministres le volet
constitutionnel de la réforme des
institutions
certaines mesures font consensus comme
la suppression de la cour de justice de
la république mais les mesures
concernant la procédure parlementaire ne
passe pas le président du sénat gérard
larcher dénonce un affaiblissement du
parlement le projet de loi de lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes examiné cette semaine en
commission à l'assemblée nationale le
débat a été particulièrement vif autour
de l'imprescriptibilité des crimes
sexuels commis sur les mineurs
l'union européenne face aux migrations
c'était le thème d'un débat en séance au
sénat
une phrase de la ministre des affaires
européennes a mis le feu aux poudres
dans l'hémicycle nathalie loiseau a
parlé de shopping de l'asile une phrase
qu'elle a regretté depuis et nous
commençons donc avec la révision
constitutionnelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier volet de la réforme des
institutions a été dévoilée mercredi en
conseil des ministres c'est l'un des
trois projets de lois de ce chantier
lancé par emmanuel macron si certaines
mesures font consensus la réforme du
travail parlementaire elle passe mal à
nathalie gloire l'objectif de l'exécutif
et de rendre plus efficace le processus
parlementaire mais certaines
propositions font déjà polémique
exemple avec l'encadrement des
amendements ceux qui n'auront aucun lien
direct avec un projet de loi serait
jugée irrecevable donc retoqué
autre changement qui concerne l'ordre du
jour le projet de loi prévoit que le
gouvernement puisse le modifier plus
facilement en y inscrivant des projets
dits prioritaires pour accélérer les
procédures
si l'adoption du texte bloc entre les
deux chambres et en commission mixte
paritaire
le gouvernement pourrait demander à
l'assemblée de statuer définitivement
afin d'apaiser les tensions edouard
philippe tente de rassurer les
parlementaires à la sortie du conseil
des ministres
l'objet de ce texte de révision
constitutionnelle sur lequel je voudrais
insister aujourd'hui n'est pas de
transformer les équilibres issus de la
vème république il ne s'agit pas de
revenir à la 4e il ne s'agit pas
d'inventer une hypothétique sixième
république il s'agit de revenir aux
équilibres de la 5e et à certains égards
même de revenir à l'esprit originel
d'autres mesures de ce projet de loi
sont plus consensuels comme la
suppression de la cour de justice de la
république
le conseil économique social et
environnemental devient quant à lui la
chambre de la société civile il prévoit
également l'inscription dans la
constitution de la corse et de la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique et
les anciens présidents de la république
ne siégeront plus au conseil
constitutionnel a chuté mal cette
réforme c'est un affaiblissement du
parlement au profit de l'exécutif sans
aucun doute
chouette mis d'accord d'abord première
chose à quoi rime cette réforme
fonctionnelle est elle une priorité pour
les françaises et français la réponse
est non
quand on fait une réforme vous modifier
la constitution c'est un élément
important
la question c'est quel droit
supplémentaire notamment sur la
démocratie qu'est ce que ça apporte aux
citoyens la réponse là aussi non donc
les français ont pensé que macron est un
réformateur
et finalement c'est un une gestion de
sacrés public à la grand-papa
on revient en arrière un temps où le
parlement n'avait pas droit de regard si
je prends deux exemples sur les
amendements être parlementaire c'est
faire la loi
donc en gros on enlève ce qui est même
l'essence même le rôle premier des
parlementaires et des assemblées de
l'autre côté on nous dit que sur
l'agenda
finalement ce qui était à la fin de 2008
qui permettait d'équilibré pas assez à
mon goût mais déjà de faire un premier
pas pour équilibrer le rapport exécutif
légitime
on revient en arrière en fait macron via
cette réforme là veut montrer ce qui se
fait ailleurs
lui seul doit décider cette réforme
c'est donner plus de pouvoirs à
maquereau et moins à tous les autres
mais il n'y a pas besoin de
rationalisation du travail parlementaire
mais ce que j'aime c'est comme j'entends
l'efficacité c'est le grand terme est
bien certain par l'efficacité moi je
parle de démocratie qu'est ce que
l'efficacité
si on peut mais il expliqué je veux bien
en débattre moi je pense à la démocratie
par exemple avancé faire en sorte que
les concitoyens puis sur un centre de
grands textes avoir la possible
d'amender comme nous l'avons fait sur la
réplique numérique
ça me semble est une avancée mais de
deux que le parlement puisse plus
facilement lui se saisir de textes et
faire des propositions moi ça me semble
être une avance parler de cette réforme
de populisme light finalement que les
citoyens fassent eux mêmes leurs
amendements ce n'est pas là aussi du et
du populisme c'est pas du populisme
ce que je propose c'est excusez moi
c'est la base la démocratie c'est de
dire que à côté des parlementaires on
puisse avoir une voix des français le
français s'est passé populisme le plus
c'est ce qui entraîne est proposé c'est
à dire qu' il n'y a aucun contre-pouvoir
les collectivités les assauts des élus
les syndicats tout ça aux deux côtés ça
n'existe plus et moi moissonne emmanuel
macron je parle directement au peuple
est-ce que la modification de la
procédure parlementaire va aussi
renforcer l'assemblée nationale au
détriment du sénat finalement le grand
perdant de cette réforme ce n'est pas le
sénat
dans le grand est le grand perdant cette
réforme c'est notre constitution je
crois contrairement à ce que dit le
premier dans votre reportage yens
modification de fait de la confusion
parce que je les dis renforcement
extraordinaire de l'exécutif et le
bicaméralisme commence à battre de l
aile j'allais dire donc oui c'est une
occasion importante et en l'état bien
avant nous sommes opposés nous les
socialistes à cette réforme est donc
maintenue macron aura bien du mal à
faire passer dire aujourd'hui je le
redis
la priorité c'est plutôt la question
économique social notre pays je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à dire sur
ce point de vue là vous socialiste vous
êtes opposés mais le premier oppose à
cette réforme il s'appelle aussi gérard
larcher deux heures après la
présentation du texte en conseil des
ministres qu'il a tenu une conférence de
presse il a affiché sa détermination et
lancé un avertissement à l'exécutif et
de l'histoire
je suis déterminé voilà les mots du
président du sénat gérard larcher monte
au créneau contre le projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui vise à réformer
les institutions
il persiste et signe l'exécutif veut
affaiblir les pouvoirs du parlement pour
la première fois dans l'histoire de la
vème république un projet de révision
constitutionnelle se propose de faire
régresser les droits du parlement
il porte atteinte à des droits des
principes essentiels et par-delà à l'
équilibre des pouvoirs au nom de
l'efficacité de gouvernement veut
accélérer et simplifier la procédure
parlementaire pour le président du sénat
ces mesures pourrait conduire un
déséquilibre démocratique
je crois aussi qu à parlement fort et
indispensable à un exécutif fort
préserver les pouvoirs du parlement
c'est préserver les fondements de la
démocratie représentative affaiblir le
parlement c'est risqué de déplacer le
débat dans la rue pour faire valider
cette réforme le volet constitutionnel
devra être voté dans les mêmes termes
par les deux chambres le projet de loi
devrait donc arriver en première lecture
à l'assemblée nationale avant cet été et
au sénat début septembre moi c'était mal
pour nous la bd vous êtes opposés à
cette réforme parce que vous soutenez
gérard larcher dans sa bataille sont que
j'ai arraché et nous avons la position
commune sur cette réforme dans son
ensemble les pas question de soutenir
pierre paul ou jacques la question c'est
est-ce que vous
entre parlementaires est ce que les
parlementaires socialistes à l'assemblée
et au sénat
nous approuvons cette réforme qui est
moins de démocratie et moins de
démocratie de parlement aujourd'hui on
nous vante la plus qu en marche la
modernité et on prends souvent l'exemple
à l'étranger les exemples qu'on ne prend
ce sont souvent des pays où il ya des
pouvoirs parlementaire fort vous faut se
faire totalement inverse
voilà donc là dessus maintenant le
premier texte arrivait je note que les
deux autres textes sont encore cachés
conseille donc au début je vous rappelle
que des tout d'être sur la table en même
temps hélas un seul texte donc nous
allons voir l'ensemble des textes et et
non à l'assemblée comme au sénat
nous sommes opposés je rappelle qu'à la
sq au sénat nous avons fait une
consultation nous les sénateurs
socialistes que nous avons fait des
propositions
oui nous avons fait des propositions
d'évolution de la concession avec
beaucoup plus démocratie d'intégration
d'un jeu nouveau et nous avons fait une
consultation et donc les citoyens
peuvent ils continuent encore à
commenter à proposer ce que nous faisons
et on peut avoir faire on peut faire et
de la démocratie
et en même temps discuter avec les
français et françaises ces deux moments
importants mais est-ce qu'on assiste
tout de même pas à finalement une
défense corporatiste à la fois des
députés et des sénateurs
mais pourquoi la défense corporatiste
ceux de l'exécutif n'existerait pas fin
juin ils sont pâles le corporatisme
s'est défendu en 48h à 244 sénateurs
mais excusez moi c'est très intéressant
c'est comme pour la suppression par
exemple de la parlementaire
elle exprime pour les parlementaires
mais elle est gardée pour les ministres
là vous nous dites que vous les cédez
les parlementaires vous soyez contre
quoi - tours - démocratie en france -
deux parlements france les oppriment des
fils de l'exécutif dont l'exécutif fait
du corporatisme si je prend vos propos
oui ça marche de fortis en la question
de la question je perdais pas celle là
la question est ce que dans une
république du 21e siècle
l'équilibré des pouvoirs qui le font
même de la démocratie et nous sommes en
ce pays qui a participé à ce qu'une
démocratie forte
est-ce que l' équilibre des pouvoirs et
où pas une réalité inestimable pour nous
notre sont louis on a c'est un débat un
débat on a bien compris votre position à
ce que selon vous le congrès va pouvoir
se réunir sur ce texte
t quand je regarde les prises de
positions des différents partis
je ne vois pas comment le présent
implique pourrait réunir sur ce
projet-là trois cinquièmes donc il ya la
question du congrès il ya la question du
référendum ne verrons dans les prochains
jours les deux autres textes montrent
que nous sommes opposés à cette révision
caution pour ce qu'il ya dedans pas par
principe mais ce cas de dons on l'a bien
noté dans l'actualité parlementaire
cette semaine elle les députés ont
débattu de la lutte contre les violences
sexuelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'assemblée les députés de la
commission des lois examinait le projet
de loi contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles renforcement de la lutte des
sanctions mais aussi de la protection
des mineurs ce sont les ambitions de ce
texte
mais la question de la prescription
notamment des viols sur mineures a
longuement été débattue alice rougerie
faciliter la répression des violences
sexuelles sur mineurs la disposition est
inscrite dès le début du texte
le premier article a pour objet
d'allonger de 10 ans le délai de
prescription applicable aux crimes
commis sur mineurs en le portant à 30
ans à compter de la majorité de la
victime
allonger le délai de dix ans est ce
suffisant
c'est ce point qui a fait débat car
certains députés veulent aller plus loin
je considère que ce crime doit être on
les mineurs un prêt serait prescrite
militer et réservée aux films contre
l'humanité mais ne pouvons nous pas
considérer finalement que la pédophilie
est un crime véritablement contre
l'humanité plusieurs députés mettent en
avant l'amnésie traumatique qui touche
de nombreuses victimes
un argument de plus pour supprimer cette
notion de temps vide et de s'assurer de
manière certes indirecte que les auteurs
de tels faits rappelons le de crimes ou
délits sexuels à l'égard d'enfants
il est tout de même important de le
souligner ne soit jamais tranquille qu'à
chaque instant ses auteurs d'actes
odieux ne puisse au même titre que leurs
victimes considéré que le temps puisse
faire le nécessaire pour effacer ces dix
actes mais la proposition est trop
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre selon la
france soumise sans doute des victimes
nous regardent des victimes auraient
envie qu'on aille plus loin que ce soit
un prescriptive et je l'entends et je
crois qu'il faut mesurer impérativement
ce que cela bouleverserait
potentiellement l'ensemble du droit
français
l'amendement n'a finalement pas été voté
le texte arrive en séance lundi à
l'assemblée est ce que pour vous
racheter malifaux rendent les crimes
sexuels commis sur des mineurs
imprescriptibles sais-tu sont très
compliquées d'abord le droit aujourd'hui
pose problème si on devait c'est ce qu'a
dit la ministre
je pense que humainement chacun peut
entendre cela est notamment
victime ou ceux leur entourage après on
sent bien que là ça ne passe pas
juridiquement je pense que le débat doit
déjà de pouvoir passer de 20 à 30 ans
qui est une avancée notable je rappelle
qu'ici un délai suffisant pour vous
déranger en tout cas je rappelle que
nous aussi d'ailleurs ici avec marie
pierre de la gontrie l'entretien il ya
eu une proposition des socialistes sur
cette même question mais dont ce texte
là il est plus large que cela il ya
aussi ce qu'elle est annoncé je vois que
les associations qui sont sur ce
combat-là concert qu'aujourd'hui il ya
de belles promesses mais il ya peu de
moyens en face les nombreuses lois de
circonstance dictées par l'émotion c'est
aussi votre sentiment
non je pense que le phare il fallait il
faut légiférer oui mais effectivement ne
pas s'arrêter à deux affaires puisque
c'est de ça dont par les associations
qui sont arrivés une dans le val d'oise
d'ailleurs et une dans 60 dans la seine
seine et marne et je pense pas que c'est
là dessus qu'on doit seulement bâtir ce
qu'est ce schéma là la question de
l'égalité hommes femmes d'une part et là
dans le cas présent des violences
sexistes et sexuelles doit être
effectivement une priorité c'est la
ministre porte bien dans la parole ces
questions là je considère que dans les
actes c'est moins vrai qu'ils roulaient
vu les actions aujourd'hui ont besoin de
moyens supplémentaires
ce n'est pas là et dans le steak cela
vous avez aussi les amendes et on verra
bien tout ça va être beaucoup plus
compliqué moi je pense que là dessus il
faut que chacun garde eu raison fasse
preuve de sérieux entendre plus les
victimes et les associations et je pense
que là dessus on pourra je l'espère en
tout cas trouver un consensus à la fin
sur un sujet hautement important pour
nos concitoyens constatent que ce projet
de loi est une réponse à la hauteur de
ses mouvements qu'on a vu sur les
réseaux sociaux et balances ton port
mitsou je ne crois pas d'heure je vous
le redis je crois que les associations
qui ont porté ces combats là qui le
portent depuis de nombreuses années qui
au quotidien font le travail que ce soit
de les coûts téléphoniques jusqu'à
l'intervention aussi de soutiens
notamment sur les dépôts et sur la suite
quand vous faites
effectivement vous faites en un dépôt et
de tout ce qui a derrière la procédure
juridique et judiciaire et les questions
de santé etc considère comme ça n'a pas
assez loin ce n'est pas à la hauteur des
ambitions
je pense que la miss doit se reprendre
et faire en sorte que ce texte là soit
la hauteur des ambitions et surtout d
vies qui sont brisées pas aussi violent
cela cette semaine le sénat organisé un
débat sur l'union européenne face aux
migrations
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un débat qui s'annonçait sans polémique
particulière mais une expression
employée par la ministre chargé des
affaires européennes a déclenché une
polémique nathalie loiseau a parlé de
shopping de l'asile quand un calice le
débat s'annonce est classique
il a été rapidement rattrapé par
l'actualité esther benbassa élus
écologistes dénoncent la politique
migratoire du gouvernement la ministre
lui répond mais lorsque l'on arrive du
sud soudan
on peut décider de faire du shopping de
l'asie les trouvais qu'on est mieux on
souhaite qu'en italie mais enfin tout de
même aujourd'hui
[Musique]
écoutez moi je suis allé au sud-sudan et
je vous invite à faire la différence
entre ces pays et les pays européens
le projet de loi asile et immigration
est dans tous les esprits car il doit
arriver au sénat dans quelques semaines
mais pourtant pour de nombreux sénateurs
c'est bien à l'échelon européen que
cette question migratoire se traite
parmi les pistes en cours de discussion
avec les partenaires européens une
augmentation du budget en matière de
contrôle des migrations mais aussi un
renforcement de frontex la police des
frontières européennes ou encore la
possibilité de réformer le règlement de
dublin sur les demandes pour les
réfugiés mais le point le plus crucial
c'est celui d'un mécanisme contraignant
de répartition des migrants en cas de
crise ou des compensations financières
pour les bons élèves en la matière
les collectivités qui accueille un
nombre important de migrants doivent
être éligibles au fonds de cohésion
c'est à la fois un soutien pour les
états qui font de réels efforts et ce
sont autant de fonds qu'ils n'iraient
pas vers les états qui refusent
d'accueillir quelques demandeurs d'asile
que ce soit mais selon certains
sénateurs
le principal déficit de nos politiques
migratoires européennes ce sont les trop
faibles reconduite à la frontière
est ce qu'il est normal au sein de la
communauté européenne que les élus ne
puisse pas se prononcer sur des plafonds
et sur un choix de personnes à
accueillir dans notre pays en fonction
de nos besoins et en fonction de notre
capacité bien sûr à intégrer ces
populations toutes ces questions
migratoires seront au coeur du conseil
européen des 28 et 29 juin prochains
lahrache était mal tout d'abord votre
réaction à ces mots employés par la
ministre shopping de l'asile abjecte
scandaleux irresponsable quand vous êtes
mis la république française pays des
droits de l'homme patrie des droits de
l'homme
c'est absolument scandaleux parce que
quand on pense au défi pour ces hommes
et ces femmes qui prennent des risques
pour leur vie même parce que quand ils
partent c'est pas de gaîté de coeur
qu'il traverse océans qui parfois tomber
dans une forme d' esclavage moderne et
caetera et
qu'ils viennent faire du shopping de
l'asile c'est scandaleux mais il faut
dire aussi que tout ça c'est une petite
musique sur la circulaire colons en
novembre dernier
les propos du midi à l'intérieur quand
tu défends des salles oise et
d'immigration qui est quand même à
quiconque va à l'encontre de ce qu'est
la tradition française avec le soutien
du front national vous voyez bien où
cela nous mène donc moi je pense surtout
aux électeurs dont je suis du second
tour
le premier tour moi j'ai voté socialiste
du second tour on a voté au second tour
contre le front national
pas pour contre le front national et on
se réveille quelques mois plus tard avec
une oie asile immigration soutenu par le
front national avec une mise qui tient
ces propos là voilà ce qu'il faut
retenir de ce ces éléments là justement
vous parlez de ce projet de
l'immigration votée à l'assemblée est ce
que pour vous c'est utile sur ce sujet
de légiférer au niveau franco française
que le problème ne se pose pas dans le
cadre européen de l'union européenne il
ya deux choses il ya les volets européen
et voyez bien on parle du budget je
souhaite une question centrale
et moi je considère que l'europe doit
effectivement sur un son de questions
assumer ce qu'elle est
quand on voit ce qui se passe avec trump
je pense que l'europe va enfin
comprendre qu'elle doit assumer son
destin qu'elle est maintenant adulte sur
un centre de grandes questions dont la
question de son budget et ça veut dire
ça des politiques publiques sur
l'éducation sur la question que j'ai et
notamment la question de la protection
et et questions des sécurité et
notamment la question migratoire
puisque nous sommes devant une crise
migratoire et qu'elle va durer et donc
bien sûr qu'au niveau européen et
donnera une réponse et l'envoyer un peu
compliqué après il doit offrir une
réponse française et la réponse
française celle qui porte aujourd'hui ne
répondent à aucune problématique et à le
fait que créer d'antagonisme entre les
uns et les autres et elles flirtent
encore une fois là le soutien de
l'extrême droite qu'être cette procédure
de dublin justement cette procédure
européenne doit-elle être revus que le
migrant doit est-ce qu'il doit pouvoir
choisir finalement c'est là toute la
question
le pays dans lequel ils souhaitent être
accueillis mais c'est pas ça la question
du bain tous bien et elle se résume pas
à ce qu'il choisisse choisit pas c'est
la question des portes d'entrée parce
que je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui vous
rentrez par des portes et on vous
renvoie c'est le pays de l'avenir à la
porte donc bien sûr on peut discuter
de l'accord de dublin mais la première
question c'est que fait l'europe face
aux défis migratoires hélas crise
migratoire et après dans les mécanismes
de réponse et à frontex il ya dublin
tout ça mais c'est la première question
à ce jour je vous rappelle que l'europe
n'a pas su ou très peu de trouver une
solution globale
il ya eu un accord qui permettait
notamment la france qui a pris sa part
je le rappelle sur le précédent
quinquennat 2 de cet effort-là d'autres
pays ne l'ont pas fait enfin il faut
regarder ce qui se passe en hongrie où
d'autres pays vont envoyer voyez bien
que il ya un débat européen
effectivement il faut qu'une petite
migratoire au niveau européen une
politique d'asile également européen
mais la france peut parce que c'est sa
culture parce que c'est son histoire
jouer un rôle d'avant garde mes pas vers
la régression pas vers le populisme pas
en essayant d'avoir les voix du front
national n'en en assumant ce qu'est la
grandeur de la france allait le 10 mai à
la fin de l'esclavagé était commémoré
[Musique]
le 10 mai c'est la date à laquelle en
2001 le sénat avait adopté la loi
taubira reconnaissant la traite et
l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité
le premier ministre a célébré jeudi les
cent soixante dix ans de la fin de
l'esclavagé par une cérémonie au sénat
et il a mis l'accent sur le devoir de
mémoire
marie frémeau donc la traite a été
abolie
notamment par les britanniques en 1807
et puis par le congrès de vienne en 1815
ils écoutent religieusement des siècles
d'histoire retracé dans le cadre d'une
exposition dans les jardins du
luxembourg le premier ministre entouré
de jean marc ayrault et du premier vice
président du sénat réunie ce 10 mai pour
commémorer l'abolition de l'esclavagé
une date pour ne jamais oublier ce jour
de commémoration nationale des mémoires
de la traite négrière de l'esclavagé et
de leurs abolitions est un moment
essentiel
enfin que chacun conserve à l'esprit
toute l'horreur de l' esclavage l'enfer
et le martyre qui connut des millions
d'hommes de femmes déracinés ollier du
confit et d'un préjugé racial au mépris
de l'humain se rappeler la traite les
pratiques inhumaines le crime légaliser
notamment pour que ces heures sombres de
notre passé collectif soit connue des
jeunes générations
mais cette journée c'est également
l'occasion de se souvenir que le sujet
reste encore d'actualité
cela signifie que la liberté et
l'égalité reste aujourd'hui des motifs
de combat car l' esclavage aliens en
cause selon les organisations
internationales plus de 40 millions de
personnes dans le monde
1 chiffres saisissants qui regroupe
toutes les formes de l' esclavage
moderne de plus en plus associé à la
migration car les individus se
retrouvent alors dans des situations
d'extrême vulnérabilité à 7 1 le présent
dans le public n'était pas présent lors
de notre cette 13e cérémonie de
commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé est ce que vous regrettez
son absence je le regrette et je
conserve c'est une faute politique
je pense que là le devant et noir est
important c'est que cette cérémonie
permet de rassembler les françaises et
les français et donc chaque fois qu'il
faut se rassembler je pense qu'il est du
rôle du devoir du chef de l'état d'être
présent dans son discours et d'affiner
part insisté sur cette mémoire des
résistants c'était important d'insister
là dessus et je suis il faut regarder la
question c'est un crime contre
l'humanité il faudra dès ce qu'elle est
dans sa globalité cirque à la fois ce
qui a participé à cet esclavage les
hommes les femmes qui l'ont combattu
tout le processus qui a conduit à cette
abolition est aussi ne pas oublier
parfois dans le
du globe la question de l'esclavagé
moderne voilà tout ça soutient et je
pense qu'il est important de le rappeler
on va finir cette émission avec quelques
questions politiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l a semaine prochaine les cent cinquante
mille cheminots sont invités par leur
syndicat se prononcer sur cette réforme
ferroviaire
l'intersyndicale demande donc aux
premiers concernés s'ils sont pour ou
contre la réforme quelle légitimité à
cette consultation a chuté mal c'est aux
salariés de décider de l'avenir dans ce
cas là on a dit avoir pas à dire en
permanence tout le monde peut parler pas
les salariés donc moi qui la
consultation ils la font et nous verrons
le résultat
ce qui est clair que cette réforme a
c'est qu'on ne comprend plus rien jusque
là aussi une réforme pour des formes le
premier c'était d'une brutalité extrême
lors de son annonce sur un signe de
grande question il n'y a pas de réponses
sur la dette qui a veut dire
l'investissement l'entretien la
modération des réseaux sur la question
des lignes secondaires qui est quand
même ce que vivent nos français les
français français au quotidien sur la
question de la qualité du service public
sur la question effectivement
l'entreprise son statut et les droits
des salariés sur ces quatre questions là
pas de réponse et je veux dire on joue
on a ils ont voté à l'assemblée un texte
il y aura au sénat sans aucune réponse
précise très rapidement a dit henin à
vous entendre sur la taxe d'habitation
on a appris cette semaine que finalement
cette promesse à l'écouté à 26,1
milliards d'euros qui va payer
les françaises et français il faut
rappeler que nous avons annoncé 10
milliards d'euros
on passe à 26,4 il faut y ajouter la
dette de la sncf près de 34 il faut y
ajouter les cadeaux fiscaux 5 milliards
pour l'is f par an 1 milliard pour
l'exit tax c'est impossible
donc on nous avait présenté une équipe
de campagne un président qui savait où
il allait force est constater qu on nous
avait vendu 10 milliards on est à 26
milliards à la fin c'est les français
qui paieront et je rappelle que la taxe
d'habitation sert à des équipements des
écoles des crèches etc
c'est important le dire merci à vous
râches était mal merci
ariane mancini c'est la fin de ce tour
de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]